how's it going everybody so there has
been a really popular Avengers for
theory going around surprise we don't
have enough of them right but this one
again it's really popular it's getting a
lot of traction and a lot of people like
it and it is a good idea it's a good
theory it's quite interesting so I'm
going to explain it to you and then I'll
break it down and give you my opinion at
the end if you are new to my channel I'm
doing an infinity war blu-ray giveaway I
have already picked two winners and will
be picking one more and then be doing a
special giveaway after that so if you'd
like to enter all you have to do is be a
subscriber like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so the theory is that
Tony Stark in Thanos have actually met
before their encounter on Titan and yes
I do know that the Russo brothers said
that Thanos knows Tony Stark from the
Battle of New York as the person who
undid his plans but this theory does
have some merit and the Russo brothers
are the people that showed us a trailer
of the Hulk running in Wakanda when we
never saw the Hulk after the first scene
so technically that shouldn't disprove
this theory right away so again this
theory states that Tony Stark and Thanos
have met before
you know me I do you're not the only one
cursed with knowledge we know that
Avengers 4 is going to have time travel
and according to this theory they say
that Tony Stark will go back in time and
fight Thanos in the past so in that
fight the present Thanos of that time
will be fighting future Tony Stark
perhaps this is why Fano says I hope
they remember you in Avengers infinity
war maybe Thanos has already seen Tony
Stark died this would explain why he's
so confused when he says Stark when he
realizes that Iron Man is Tony Stark we
think Fanus is confused because he
realizes that this is Tony Stark
this is the guy that sent a nuclear bomb
into my army but perhaps he's confused
thinking this is stark this is the guy
that I watched die years ago this
could also explain thinness 'as reaction
when Tony Stark asked him you know me
and he says I do when he says I do
it's almost sentimental like I do know
you I watched you die heck he probably
even killed him himself so that's the
theory and it's an interesting theory
that actually falls into the time travel
plot of Avengers for there are
definitely ways that it does fit and
work for the storyline however I
personally do not think it's very
plausible and the reason I think that is
because wouldn't Thanos recognize
Ironman right away by his armor
I mean if Tony Stark and Thanos fought
in the past there's no way Tony Stark's
going to battle without his Iron Man
suit so he would have recognized him
right away when he saw Iron Man he
wouldn't have had to hear his voice to
know it start he knows that Tony Stark
is Iron Man if he fought him in the past
this is why I don't think this theory is
very plausible I think he would
recognize him the instant he saw his
armor which pokes a hole in this theory
dad I just don't think you can get
around but let me know your thoughts do
you think it's possible that Thanos and
Tony Stark could have fought in the past
and do you think that this is the true
reason that Thanos knows Tony Stark let
me know your thoughts in the comments
below and again the infinity war blu-ray
giveaway continues if you would like to
enter all you have to do is be a
subscriber like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero thank you all so much
for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]